[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
ladies and gentlemen
i'm delighted to welcome all of you here
in brussels at the atelier
for all of you that made it here
physically in presence
and all of you that are following us
online by
our web streaming
this is the first edition of the new
european bauhaus crisis awards
and i'm really really happy also to see
all the nominees here physically in
presence in brussels almost all of you
made it here today and this is a very
special day
and i'm also very proud to be here
representing the high level roundtable
of the new european bauhaus
since we started in september 2 2020
when the european commission president
ursula van der leyen announced this
program
and then after six months of intense
participatory
co-working and co-designing phase with
all our partners
now we can be very happy because we
reach our first milestone which is this
price award ceremony
if the european green deal has a soul
this is the european the new european
bauhaus
this is what commissioner maria gabriel
said in one of the other meetings and
this is what the president of the
european commission said yesterday
in a
state of the union speech in the
parliament in strasbourg
the new european bauhaus wants to couple
the european green deal with a real
cultural and artistic movement
so that the grand vision of the european
green deal can become real tangible and
concrete projects that show how
sustainable innovation can change our
daily life
the daily life of people of communities
in cities in countrysides in all places
across europe in rural areas and also in
urban communities but it can also change
many economic sectors
from construction to fashion to textile
to energy to our built environment
by bridging science technology and
innovation with arts and culture and
also by bringing together
sustainability and good design
we can put uh forward solutions that are
more sustainable consume less carbon but
that are also affordable and accessible
for all of us
so today your work
and the work of all the nominees will
show us that this is possible that is
already existing or that
it's gonna show how the future will look
like
so before
diving into our ceremony we do have the
pleasure and the honor thanks to our
partnership with lamone
and of course arts and music is also
part of the new european
bauhaus values
we have a
music performance by singer
lucas cortez and pianist emmanuel
turbelan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
the
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
many many thanks to the artists
and now
we have a contribution we have a video
message from the president of the
european commission ursula van der leyen
unfortunately she couldn't be here with
us in brussels today but she wanted to
send her strong words from strasbourg in
the european parliament where yesterday
she delivered the state of the union
speech with a specific communique on the
new european bauhaus where she has new
instruments and actions and funding for
this program in the future
the nominees
my dear commissioners elise and maria
dear guests
i wish i could be with you in brussels
today
it would have been a joy to experience
all the talent and the innovative ideas
and i'm sure you will have a great time
together
before
i hand over the floor to my colleagues
to finally reveal the winners of the new
european bauhaus prize
let me say a few words on the nominated
projects and also on the new european
bauhaus itself
so
first dear nominees
congratulations on making it to this
very last stage of the competition
your projects were selected from over 2
000 applications from all over europe
you impressed both
the audience and the experts
and you all impressed me
your projects and your visions gave us a
lot of hope for our european green deal
and you not only show what is possible
you also show that change is happening
already all of our european union in all
sectors of our economy and society
the new european bauhaus is something
very special since we launched it a year
ago
it has been amazing to see it grow
so many contributions so many events
so many fruitful conversations
so much talent skill and innovation
and such diversity
i saw an amazing amount of interest from
all walks of life
i'm delighted
but i also asked myself
why this happened
i'm convinced that it's because the new
european bauhaus
combines the big vision of the european
green deal
with tangible change on the ground
change that improves our daily life
change that people can touch and feel in
buildings in public spaces they can see
it
in our cities and villages
they can even feel it on our skin
as far as sustainable fashion for
example is concerned
it is extremely rewarding and great fun
to create together with all of you a new
style of living
a lifestyle that matches sustainability
with good design
a lifestyle that needs less carbon
that reconnects us with nature
and a lifestyle that is inclusive and
affordable for all
making this happen
is a huge challenge
but now you
the nominees of the new european bauhaus
prize
are an important part of this journey
you are living proof that it is possible
let me also say that i was very pleased
when i saw so many young people
participating in this competition
when it comes to climate change it is
younger generations in particular
who will experience the effects of
global warming
to make sure that our planet remains
livable
we need the energy and the ideas of
young talents
as much as we need the know-how and
skills
of our more experienced supporters
now
i want to leave the floor to today's
most important people
the winners of the new european bauhaus
prize 2021
i wish you all a great evening and thank
you for having me on screen with you
and many thanks president for this very
energizing message to all our nominees
so now we open the awards ceremony
and we award the winners in the first
five categories
for each category we will award the nab
awards for existing completed projects
and nab rising stars for concepts and
ideas by young talents
i just want to remind you that the
winners listing and selection was based
on public voting and then by an
evaluation committee composed of the
official partners of the new european
bauhaus
i now invite the commissioner for
cohesion and reform elisa ferreira
to come on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much and
thank you to all of you for being here
and in fact today today is the day of
celebration
celebration of ideas
celebration of achievements
celebration of the pioneers that you are
who proved that green is not grey
that europe's green future can be
beautifully designed
elegantly lived
and include
everybody for the first edition of the
new european bauhaus awards
we received as the president just said
more than 2 000 applications
i was tremendously impressed we're all
very impressed by their quality and
ingenuity
and i must say
that
2 000 projects spanning
europe
and even beyond spanning many different
fields
looks very much to me
like what we wanted the beginning of a
movement
these past six months
have been eye-opening
i have heard from people all over europe
who want to change how we live
who want a better future
and who want to breathe their life their
energy into our green deal commitments
expressing them in real life projects in
something of everyday life
in their local communities in their
families in their homes
your examples
your ideas
show that it is not too late
there are those who worry that the green
lifestyle
will be difficult or limiting
a luxury
that only one will be able to afford
you have proved that
sustainability does not have to be
difficult or out of reach
that we can embrace these changes
in style
maintaining strong local communities and
strong local economies
so
dear finalists
you can all be proud you are the
trailblazers
you are the shining examples of how to
do sustainability
and how to do it well
i hope that
many others will follow your examples
and what examples they are
i'm looking forward to it already
so francesca
what do we have
yes so thank you very much for the
speech
and we now move to category number one
which is reinvented places to meet and
share
and i know the the commission want to
say something about this
yes we are in one of those places this
place is the exact illustration of how
you transform something from the past
into something from the for the future
something a place
where we meet for cultural events for
being together for enjoying our presence
together
so in this category we were looking for
inspirational examples of how spaces can
be used for positive exchanges and
community building
we have six nominees for the first
category
let's go to see who they are and know
their projects
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winners are
so the awards go to
julia garden
and from rising stars
social reconstruction in post-emergency
yes please come on stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations
you made it
you look very excited so julia garden we
have clara yeah i'm clara and uh well
escari casco thank you gracias
merci
it's
amazing for a great
for a grassroots organization like us
to be here today in brussels
this means that the commitment of the
communities and the commitment of the
people
still has a strong
joint power
so
please european commission
and european union use this power to put
the
life in the center
to make it sustainable and please make
it real and not only reading passing
also i wanna thanks to the community of
yulia
and to my partners we are
seven girls
seven women
gracias ainara
thank you
great
so now the award please come at the
center of the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
okay and then ludovica social
reconstruction in post-emergency
hello hello everyone and
thank you so much for trusting this
project it's a solo project i'm carrying
out but obviously i was not gonna be
here if it wasn't for my tutor my
colleagues and friends my family and
also i want to thank the community that
really supported me
when i was studying the case study of
tools and back in italy because without
the residents i was working with i was
not gonna make it at all so thank you
thank you to the community and thank you
european commission for believing in the
strength of communities
congratulations
[Music]
well done
thank you and congratulations again
so we now go immediately to the second
category which is uh techniques
materials and processes for construction
and design
we were looking at products and
processes that contribute to a
sustainable attractive and inclusive
lifestyle
we have six nominees and we go to see
who they are and what their projects are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winners are
for the awards
earthen pure walls
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and into category of rising stars
inhabiting an enclosed landscape
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
martin yeah
congratulations thank you
thanks to my fantastic team to my family
in austria
earth as a building material has no
lobby
this is why i am very happy that this
building system with 100 percent
earth
gets the power supplies because it needs
more visibility
i am convinced that unstabilized earth
ramped earth construction is essential
for building sustainable
it exists everywhere and has
the proof of history that is works in
every climate zone and continent
including europe
we just need more trust courage and
creativity to use this old building
materials with new tools in a modern way
and in architectural design
let's go
less concrete
more earth
let's go
[Music]
well congratulations very well done
and now we have javier gavin balda
i come here representing a team of three
we are siddhartha juan and myself javier
we would like to thank the valeric
institute of housing the ibabi for
giving us the chance to develop this
project
i really encourage all of you to take a
look at the work they're doing and their
research towards sustainability and
ecology it's really interesting and
social housing and the kind of projects
they develop i mean it's totally worth
and
apart from that we would also like to
thank all the people who voted us on
these
rounds and also the organization and the
new european house for taking such a
strong stand towards sustainability
thank you thank you and the world
[Applause]
yeah continue
congratulations
so we move um
to the third
category
for the co-evolution of built
environment and nature
we're going to see examples showing how
the built environment may contribute to
the protection of nature and
biodiversity taking into account
cultural and social needs
also for this category we have six
nominees and we're gonna see who they
are and what they do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and in the awards we have
the winner
is rosanna
and in rising stars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rising stars the winner is
nest
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so for rosanna we have anna i guess here
and also martin roush which is not is
there okay yeah again
yeah
yeah on behalf of my co-author martin
rao and myself we would like to thank
our clients family good schmidt our all
the fantastic craftsmen and women on the
side like family gardener emmanuel
herringer christian schulte
and of course also um there's also
further planners like martin um so
building with with timber with willow
with fibers with earth there's a lot of
earth also in this building in europe
currently is costly is more costly than
building with concrete with styrofoam
with steel and this is not the problem
of the material of the nature of the
material per se but it's a problem of
our economic system that taxes human
energy craftsmanship very highly and
carbon and co2 emissions very low
but the good news is
like the economic system is not a force
of nature it's man-made so we can change
it
[Laughter]
yes and
we are deeply convinced if we work more
with natural building materials our
homes our work spaces our cities our
villages would become not just more
healthy and sustainable but also more
humane and beautiful thank you i agree
good speech
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
and for the project nest we have
magdalena ross
hello
thank you it is an honor to be here
tonight and a dream come true thank you
to the european commission to all the
institutions and people involved in the
new european bauhaus
for us nest is just the beginning and
tonight it's a huge milestone for our
young office that is developing projects
that are inclusive sustainable and
beautiful we're not alone on this planet
we're surrounded by beautiful nature by
beautiful creatures and we need to
celebrate it we need to find a way to
live in a harmony together there's a lot
to do but with initiatives like this
we are really excited and really hopeful
for the future thank you congratulations
and their words
congratulations
[Applause]
very well done
go on
goodbye thank you
very good and we move now to category
number four which is buildings renovated
in the spirit of circularity
we were looking for physical spaces that
demonstrate the reuse and recycling of
materials a core element of the new
european
bauhaus and the green deal
so we have
six nominees also here
and we're gonna see
what are the projects that they
submitted and who they are
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
in the worlds we have
gardens in the air
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as a rising star the winner is
zero waste house
[Applause]
[Music]
for guardians in the air we are
francisco jose pasos garcia
well
[Laughter]
many thanks to the european commission
commission to the team of the new
european bauhaus
and to the rest of the of the of the of
the nominees this is awesome
our project
is a collective project we are thousands
of colleagues of entities in this
project um but i like i would like to
thank especially the collaboration of
the institute of arts and and culture of
the council of seville
thermo fisher fundacionbox bansavadel
but especially the local community
represented by the association education
educational social association of la
candelaria with their children with
their teenagers we've been working
recycling the waters of the air
conditioner to create new ecosystems
we we have been exploring the how to
distill essences from the nature of the
of the neighborhood in a neighborhood in
the in the periphery of seville in the
periphery of europe and also trying to
reinforce their identity the
multiculturality
through the creation of contemporary art
i just want to say a negative that we
have on the celebration concert
in last december a neighborhood a
neighbor sorry an elder woman told us
that this seems to be europe
and the president of the of the
candelaria association proudly
replied that this is because we are in
europe and today for us we are in the
heart of europe thank you very much
congratulations
[Music]
and zero waste house andre fiderse
thank you i really didn't expect to be
on this stage today so i will use this
opportunity
to remind all of us why we are here so
let's hold a few seconds of silence for
all the human and non-human lives lost
in the past and the future of climate
crisis
so yeah i mean we cannot live in despair
and our project is orientated towards
utopia towards an europe which is
circular towards social ecology and all
of your projects are in immense
inspiration when i was reading through
them
i got like a little bit of hope back
so i really believe that
we can do it like we can like solve this
problem and iotopia is within our reach
however
we should demand action we should work
and do something now
thank you
thank you very much
yes we go now to the fifth category
which is regenerated urban and rural
spaces
example of territorial regeneration that
combines sustainability aesthetics and
inclusion and that were developed with a
deep engagement of communities and
citizens we have six nominees and let's
see who they are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and in category of awards awards the
winner is
la fabrica de toda
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and our rising star
is
porto di mare eco district
helena ortiz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can you hear me yes no
thank you so much i'm super excited and
super happy i'm proud like a grandma
level of proud
because i am here on behalf of la
fabrica and that means i am here on
behalf of so many people like many of
them are from my village my family and
friends but so many of them i don't know
and they made big contributions to a
space just because they wanted to and
because it was beneficial for someone in
society
i believe we share something with all
those people i didn't know and is that
we believe in other people's intentions
and we believe we can find our own way
to create our future so let's keep going
please thank you so much
there you go
congratulations thank you very much
um
it's a great honor to be here today
i have no speech prepared so i'm very
sorry
really i have no words to to say thank
you very much to the european commission
and to this amazing project of new
european bauhaus
because i think that only
investing in in people
[Music]
could really do at the revolution we are
young with
not only the young people can can make
something
and then also this project is not a solo
project i would like to thank you also
my
my my friends and mates ali and i and
the coralie
i hope you are live
online so thank you very much
and
so
i hope that this project
really
gave a second life to a brownfield near
milan
and also turn on the light
on
communities and
place to to meet and share ideas
and lives thank you very much
congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations and go on
very good
congratulations and thank you very much
the commissioner
ferreira for awarding this first five
prizes thank you
so now we move to the remaining five
categories and for this i invite on
stage maria gabriel which is
commissioner for innovation research
culture education and youth please maria
gabriel come on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much dear
francesca dear elisa dear friends yes
it's time to talk about culture
education youth innovation
sustainability
and i must say that what i have just
seen amazes me it's your enthusiasm your
professionalism your creativity
because yes with your projects and with
your ideas
we all can see that the new european
bauhaus
it's not only an initiative of the
future
but that already exists everywhere
around us
in every corner in europe
in cities in rural areas
and
the creative and sustainable solutions
we presented
through your applications also show that
this is very
much a project of hope
a project raising great interest from
old citizens
in all their diversity and across all
ages
as demonstrated by the number of
applications received in both strands
let me say that i'm particularly glad
that so many young people participated
your projects show that by joining
forces
across the arts education research and
innovation
we can build sustainable inclusive and
accessible environments
that improve the quality of life for us
all
and this confirms the added value of
this award
the new european bauhaus price
represents the link between the
co-design and the delivery phase
and then for this reason i'm happy to
say
that we decided to continue organizing
this price every year
highlighting different dimensions of the
new european bauhaus
we announced that in our communication
published yesterday and i would like
really to bring to you to your attention
the importance of the different
initiatives and instruments that we
share with you in order to see much more
projects
everywhere in europe because you all you
are an inspiration for us
so
as we very much count on you
as well as on the entire community
to make the new european bauhaus a
tangible reality and now dear francesca
let's discover the winners of the next
five categories
yes thank you very much dear
commissioner so we move to the sixth
category which is preserved and
transformed cultural heritage
we were looking for models of
preservation that enhanced access to
cultural heritage
and conversion of heritage
infrastructure with high social purpose
and low carbon footprint we have here
also six nominees and we're eager to
discover who they are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the winner for the new european
bauhaus award is
sephora's rooftop floating wild garden
spain
and in our category rising star is
retrofitting the unesco site of eurea
italy
[Music]
maria
maria
okay congratulations so we have actually
sergio karatala la marca that's
connecting online
so he will appear
hello congratulations
thank you so much
this is amazing
you want to say a few words
yes sure
as everyone i would like to thank
the organization the new european
powerhouse and the european union for
this amazing initiative
i would like to
congratulate all the nominees and and
winners
uh thank you for the five nominations
and this prize has been amazing oh
they're all the right
and uh obviously this spread has been
not
a solo project there's been a lot of
people involved in this project
from the city government of barcelona
that launched the design competition
that sparked this uh
this fuel
that
got to this design it's a very complete
design all across disciplines from
architecture to heritage renovation to
engineering
gardening landscaping so everyone is
involved i would like to thank to all
the team
that is not here with me today but it's
represented by me and
this gives us a ton of energy green
energy to keep going and rig wild all
the cities in europe thank you very much
thank you very much
of course we cannot give you the award
in presence but it's here
we're gonna we're gonna send it yes
just to say congratulations it's yours
enjoy with your team thank you you will
receive it in a few days
okay and we have now giuseppe albiati
congratulations yes thank you
i'd like to thank the european
commission
all the the people that organize the new
european vows
and
here i represent also my friends and
colleague fortunato with whom i
developed this this project
and i think this kind of projects about
the unesco sites and important buildings
show how we can also go farther the
idea of
environmental
sustainability showing that exists also
the the theme of cultural sustainability
that means preserving
uh the the european culture that is as
well important as the natural
issue thank you
[Applause]
okay so we move to the seventh category
which is modular adaptable and moving
living solutions
looking for innovative solutions of
intervention or housing that respond to
temporary emergency needs with high
aesthetics and sustainable standards
let's go to see who the six nominees are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner
for the new european bauhaus award is a
prop steward at vela spain
and for rising stars homeless housing
denmark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do we have david juarez
[Laughter]
[Applause]
muy bien david
[Music]
yes david thank you thank you very much
i would say i didn't expect it but it's
not true i had my
slight hope uh of course that's in the
name of a huge
team this is a multi-disciplinary team
that involves
people from the municipality and a white
group of architects among them ulia
architecture and jaisa turret
and
the project is
something that
took us some years to develop along with
the public institution and it's a major
issue for us i mean to have affordable
housing in the central neighborhoods
where people are being evicted where
there are homeless people that really
need a place to be but to be in their
own neighborhoods so with this program
what we try to do is this kind of
tactical housing that can be done in a
quick sustainable modular and reversible
way so thank you very much this is very
important for the project thank you very
much
[Applause]
congratulations
okay
very good
and now
to you
hi
thank you very much it's a great honor
um
yeah i'm very happy that
the problem is is being acknowledged by
the european commission
and now it's possible for me to keep
working on it so hopefully one day it
will be realized
thank you
congratulations
[Applause]
we are proud of you
okay
so we move to the eighth category
which is products and lifestyle
products and processes that contribute
to sustainable and attractive and
inclusive lifestyles
we have six nominees for this category
as well and let's see who they are and
the projects they submitted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner for the new european
bauhaus award is air sustainability
platform portugal
and in our category rising stars it's
material unite italy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so for the nab award we have katarina
hello thank you very much for saying
it's an honor to receive this new
european by house award in fact it is
the result of the work of our team
during the last six years since cop 21
in paris so i'm here representing all of
them they are an amazing team
and that sayo we are totally committed
to carbon neutrality that's why we have
developed this air platform a
sustainability platform to
design to achieve a carbon natural
society rewarding citizens for their
sustainable actions and it's not only
about technology it's about creativity
it's about design it's about social
innovation it's about people
so air requires a new way of
a new way of thinking and acting a
mindset of transformation new
sustainable lifestyles that's why we
want we will also want to thank the
municipality of matus english the city
of metro zing is our city where is
located and where air has been deployed
for the first time thank you very much
congratulations
congratulations
[Applause]
very well done
and for materia unite we have jacob
cardinali
thank you
yeah
thank you whole thank you to the jury of
the new european bauhaus
i think that every student about design
architecture knows bauhaus and what does
it mean 100
years ago for europe for the world
uh and to be here to the new european
babas prize and winning this it's
amazing so i want to say thank you to
the jury
thank you to the jury to believe in our
project and believe that sustainable
furniture can be accessible to all in
europe and i want to say thank you the
biggest thank you is for my team
lorenzo lorenzo alessandro uh
bianca that it's following us online
and for our friend and everyone believe
in us thank you very much
congratulations
for the entire thing
okay
and we move now to category number nine
mobilization of culture arts and
communities
examples that illustrate the impacts
of the arts for sustainable community
building let's see who the six nominees
are and let's see their projects
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner for the new european
bauhaus award is esserie urbani from
italy
rising star spaces to reconnect citizens
with cities spain
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so for siri urbani angela
yeah
hello hi thank you congratulations
thank you
i'm here with the team we are so proud
we want to thank you
the commission
the organization our supporters and we
are a small association so this is a
real opportunity to promote and to
improve our projects so thank you
thank you
so we have your award here
[Applause]
okay and then we have chiara
thank you
can you hear me yes okay i'm so excited
i am here representing the shifting lab
team
so i would like to thank also julia
francesca marco the evil team and we
would like to thank the european bauhaus
for giving us the opportunity to be here
and to share
with you the the project
our team was born during the pandemic
period so
a moment of crisis that led us to
revelate our perspectives so this
project that is
a mix from
systemic design and sustainable
architecture was born during this period
of rethinking
and so
thank you again to give us this
opportunity
congratulations
congratulations
so we are now in the last category
interdisciplinary educational modules
includes innovative models of training
based on the interdisciplinary
integration of science the arts and
social studies
let's see who the nominees are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner for the new european
bauhaus award is the green design
universitat de navarra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the winner
our rising star is classic lima from
germany
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so carlos congratulations
well i am here in representation of the
school of architecture of the university
of navarra and i like to thank the
european commission and also the
organization of the new european bauhaus
when we start to design our degree in
design
we think immediately in the original
bauhaus
and
i think this price is is a confirmation
that we were in the right
way
well i'd like to thank uh to
all our teachers and students that they
are doing possible to build this future
thank you very much
congratulations
[Applause]
thank you
congratulations
and for classic lima we have an elena
schubert
thank you so much um crazy klima is very
honored
to be awarded this prize
we are in a global ecological crisis
and this means that we must
fundamentally revisit creative practice
and put it in the service of climate
justice
kazakhima is a growing collective of
dozens of young artists designers and
activists
advocating for climate justice in art
design and institutional policy thank
you so much
congratulations here
okay so thank you very much uh
commissioner
gabriel and uh i now ask you to stay
with me and come both on stage
for the final words because we are at
the end of the
of this fantastic ceremony please here
and i think we saw how many projects are
so inspiring grassroots and with the
help of a big community with funding
with instruments we can help them scale
and deliver systemic change so to you
the final words
after what we saw well i think this was
really an amazing event as i started by
saying
i think i would like to congratulate
all the winners but also to congratulate
and thank
all those that participated the 2000
participants this is the starting of a
real movement
and let me
thank also the team
uh
some of a lot of voluntary people that
joined in and have helped us to organize
this
the intention is in fact
to
ask you
to
share
to share what you have done what you
have thought you could do
so that you get inspiration
all over europe and
also in the countries that are also
participants and you can't imagine how
many proposals we received from outside
europe so this is really starting a
movement a world movement
and the intention is
of course to honor your effort to honor
your work but
above everything
to ask others to look at what you have
done and that this becomes an
inspiration
we are after the crisis after the covet
crisis we have created in europe
exceptional means
to support a recovery but we cannot
recover
our communities our economies our
societies on the old paradigm
so what we have to do now is to build
back better but this is not an issue for
politicians and for
i mean
mayors only it's for all of us
everybody that is a citizen like you are
has the duty to share and to engage with
others so that you really make the best
of the cohesion funds and of all the
defense that
all the countries have available to them
and this is the kind of message i would
like to share with you
thanking you once again and asking you
to speak with everybody that is not yet
registered that is not participating
there will be a follow-up several
follow-ups of this event this is just
the first one so let's really start a
movement in which our future will be
more sustainable
more affordable and more beautiful
because this is what makes our life
a better life for us
and for the young generation that most
of you are but you'll have children and
we have to give them a decent planet
with a different a decent quality of
life so thank you once again and this is
all i'd like to say to you today
thank you thank you
and for commissioner gabriel also i
think because the commission is
absolutely committed to make sure that
this is going to last longer but since
we see on the map all the projects that
submit it i think we still want to do a
lot of work to make sure that all
europeans and even beyond europe because
we are engaging a global community can
really get engaged so we have a lot of
work to do to make it even more
successful absolutely and that will be
my triple message to you first of all
congratulations again i think that we
all can feel the emotion that we have
now thanks to you to your creativity to
your talents to your ideas so my first
message is please continue to be a role
model a role model for entire
communities for regions for places where
we need to really hear a real change you
are this inspiration and you incarnate
this this ambition the second yes be the
best ambassador of the new european
bauhaus initiative because it's true
that there will be other editions but
i'm sure that everyone will always
remember
what were the first winners in our
categories that's why you have this
responsibility now to be an ambassador
and to see how we can touch all those
that were not here with us today that
yes aspire to be with us and final
message be built be bold innovate
preserve
something that you have as unique
because every one of us can feel that
with your talents and with your project
and really there there because there is
no boundaries with the new european
bauhaus there is no boundaries with your
talent and your creativity and yes it is
up to all of us
really to transform the european green
deal into a cultural project project
that touches every single citizen in
every single region because the soul of
this new european greeting is every one
of you this is the new european bauhaus
thank you thank you so much
so i think the messages are very clear
be bold be radical continue to innovate
and make your sustainable projects even
stronger because europe is serious this
time as you saw uh the president of the
european commission yesterday uh
launched and it was adopted a new
communique specifically on the new
european bauhaus please go and read it
because it is ambitious it has fundings
it has new policy instruments and it has
a path forwards to shape our future and
of course we can only do it together
with all of you and we need to be a
movement and the community to make sure
that the green deal becomes actionable
and we improve the life of all citizens
in europe
and before we conclude our fantastic
ceremony i would like to thank everybody
that has been working on this uh project
of course again the president of the
european commission that couldn't be
with us today but she really is with us
anyways of course the two commissioners
for their passion and also their
presence and their really strong words
uh and the messages that are giving the
nab a high-level round table so all my
colleagues that are following us online
i'm sure
and then all the partners starting for
la monet and the performers that will
delight us again but that already
performed today
then the forest gym bank of kosciuszko
in poland of course the new european
bauhaus team and the joint research
center hello savier
and then ruth reichstein and simiona
manova that are always together with us
and dg regio thanks for producing this
fantastic event and many more all the
partners of the new european bauhaus and
of course all of you that participated
and all of you all the nominees and the
winners that are here today with us in
brussels thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
h
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Applause]
you